but i mean if you're into weave stuff
it's not all akihabara of course that's
like the big mainstream place i i
personally recommend for weeb stuff
that's not akihabara not gonna knock on
broadway i was gonna say because i feel
like with with akihabara you get
overwhelmed maybe that's what you want
maybe you want to be overwhelmed with
weep stuff but the problem with the
problem with akihabara is that it's very
very much aligned with
let's say let's say weeb culture as
opposed to you know more other
underground anime culture which you can
you can find more
cool stuff in akihabara i i'd say i
don't know
more cool stuff in nakano broadway
because the way i the way i describe
akihabara is it's just like imagine if
you're on in on the convention floor
right that's that's basically akihabara
where you're on you're you're in the
dealers the dealer's hole that's
akihabara uh nakano broadway is more
like the artist alley where you can get
rid of like the
more more like
more stuff that's not my shops around
there like the unconventional stuff the
unconventional stuff right like in not
gonna broadway you know there's a store
on the first floor where they just sell
nothing but old anime cells yeah yeah
that place is really dope and then
there's other ones that are like from
like 40s and 50s japan styled stuff and
everything huge store there if you like
retro games and you want gamecube games
or something that's really cheap there's
a place called book off oh yeah oh yeah
look off sells a lot of
hand stuff yeah i mean that's
yeah yeah so many dude i saw like super
mario sunshine in box for like 600 yen
yeah so like five bucks nice yeah book
off is like a uh it's like a big chain
here isn't it yeah you can find book
offs in
most major places there is a book off
somewhere so if you want a good deal for
second-hand stuff just like a bunch of
them there's book off which is mostly
focused on like books and games and
stuff like that and then there's another
one called the name's horrible but it's
called hard off
i didn't really think that one through
uh which is more like kind of like
second-hand like appliances and like you
can get you can games you can get games
at heart off as well yeah um but uh yeah
and then book off you can also buy like
second-hand clothes as well yeah
this is pretty good and then there's
another one there's another version of
the off series
yeah right off i don't know
yeah because like
like my big problem with akihabara isn't
just the fact that it's like all anime
which you know that's not really that's
not really an issue it's just like you
can't really find anything else so like
if you want to go out for a nice meal
afterwards there's nothing really around
akihabara i think the only thing i've
had in akihabara is the royal host and
the the uh the ramen the ramen or if you
want to drink some ramen to be fair yeah
well if you want like sorry i don't know
i was about to say but what i love about
nakano is that nakano not only has this
like kind of cool underground like
especially in broadway the whole anime
and like weeb [ __ ] yeah but once you go
outside of the broadway section of
nakano which is just one building yeah
then it has some of the coolest bars and
restaurants restaurants and stuff i mean
the jojo bar is in nagano yeah exactly
so that's the perfect reason to go to
nakano that's that's a business i do
want to stay afloat it's going outside
grindr yeah
the jojo bar it's [ __ ] amazing yeah
that that's a place that we want to stay
in business not the maid cafes bring
your business to the jojo bar
on twitter though yeah yeah you have to
follow them on twitter
even though the google hours say
whatever he tweets out whether he's open
or not yeah because it's literally just
one person it's one dude yeah yeah so
yeah like like that's another reason to
go to nakano but aside from that there's
just so many other cool places and other
cool restaurants and bars that you can
go to in nakano and it's one of those
places where you can just stumble upon a
place you know you don't need to google
uh you don't need to do a mailing and
like google which one's like five star
or something it's one of those places
that you can just get lost in there
you're just like oh that place that
place looks cool everything's so
tight-knit yeah and like so many tiny
restaurants and uh and bars and stuff
like that yeah cause like i'm like when
i go on holiday right i'm not the kind
of person who is just like planning out
everything i don't have an itinerary
what i prefer
is just going into a cool area and just
discovering stuff for myself you know
that's that's the kind of traveler that
i am and
yeah and uh
traveler he is well well well we're a
travelled man
no the monk in him sure knows absolutely
of course of course and uh nakano is
like one of the best areas for that i
agree i agree yeah yeah i wonder so you
we've gone to akihabara what else is
something that like you might consider
you know i i think even though
you know we don't really go there that
often anymore because i feel like it's
very much uh you got to do it while
you're here
do a taba nomihoudai just go crazy for
it to go to like a cheap izakaya oh yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah everything it's like
it's like x amount do you remember how
many times we went to like kinokura
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah if you've gotta go to
akinakura if
yeah no no you don't need to know that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] or susame as conan just
said and nomihoudai which is all you can
drink which is which is the only the the
only two words you really need right
now
or you can drink i feel like you'll know
it's nomihoudai because it'll be very
bright and it'll have a number yeah yeah
it'll be like 2 000 and you'll see a
picture of a lot of drinks yeah it'll be
like 2 000 something or two if you see a
timer like two thousand plus sixty
something yeah you're either about to
hire a person for uh illegal activities
or you're going to be having an
all-you-can-drink so
fun for all the family really yeah yeah
yeah basically yeah just go just go to
an izakaya do you recommend going to a
chain one yeah [ __ ] yeah do you go to a
kinokura do you yeah
english on the table yeah that's true
or like any of those like chains like
although it's not like the highest of
quality in terms of food but like i
think if you want like 20 yeah what's it
called again
yeah that's decent look is good i really
like all of you it's literally just all
um uh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you can i think
they have
nomi and tabi hold on yeah so you can
get all you can eat and or you can drink
meat and beer i mean and honestly we're
we're saying the food isn't that good
but i remember coming here oh no it's
compared to this it's [ __ ] amazing
compared to probably where you're from
japan we we have been spoiled our food
tastes uh we've become food snobs
because i remember i remember the first
day that connor came to japan and i took
him to akinokura the moment he got off
the plane yeah and he was like it's a
hundred yen for a beer and i'm like yep
and he was like oh but it's like it's
probably like a cup right out comes a
[ __ ] like pint yeah
this is the greatest country in the
world exactly exactly yeah literally
yeah no the food the food the food is
good i i i forget i forget because i've
been living so long uh if you're
traveling out of england the food is
like [ __ ] 10 out of 10.
compare compared to anything you can get
in england this is just like a basic guy
obviously if you've been to japan a
bunch you really [ __ ] know this [ __ ]
you do whatever you want but this is for
the the boys and girls out there who are
coming to japan first yeah
yeah
everywhere you go to have the most 10
out of 10 food because you all have the
most 10 out of 10 food and uh learn like
go go do karaoke just just go speaking
of nomi horde yeah speaking of nami hoda
you will definitely need to know that
word for karaoke because basically every
karaoke has nami hoda and i don't know
why you'd want to do karaoke so but
maybe you do maybe you have a great
singing voice i don't i need to be drunk
to sing okay it will probably be a bit
awkward because they don't have like any
english help
yeah getting it just yeah i mean you'll
be fine i'm sure they used to follow
just yeah just say the
held up the number of hours you want in
your hands yeah and then say nomihoudai
and they'll tell you a price and then
you just say yes and i feel there's like
a weird i guess like stereotype of like
this karaoke culture outside of japan
because i think when most people think
of karaoke they think of like open mic
like on a stage and stuff like that
which is like i'm not for that yeah i
think that's kind of cringe because i
love it dude i love it what do you want
to do i don't know i can't i can't do it
i like tequila
i like singing in front of you know my
friends and people i know in a room
because that's fun like we can all hang
out okay
the reason the reason i'm not really a
fan of like the open mic karaoke
is because you only get two types of
people that do it
it's either one the [ __ ] amazing
singers who are basically auditioning
for x factor or something the next day
or you just get the piss heads who'd
like who just murder your ears
like okay
there is no like the thing is there is
no in between yeah you you either come
out getting a free concert or you come
out regretting the fact that you have
ears yeah there is like no between
there's never a moment where like
someone finished the scene and you're
like hey that was okay
yeah i think i like there's karaoke bars
in japan where you can sing with
everyone else i love them they're so fun
because i remember everyone everyone
gets involved everyone in the bar like
gets hyped yeah well you can do that
with like a small crowd in a karaoke
room right but what if you just want to
like meet some random japanese people
those things oh yeah i mean but i feel
there's better ways to meet japanese
people than a [ __ ] open mind karaoke
no no it's the best way but like i i
remember because i never really thought
about it because in my head karaoke was
always you know the the japanese style
character yeah like in a room right so
like i remember when uh when felix uh
came to japan and i really wanted to
take him to a karaoke in his head he was
like no i don't want to go to karaoke
why and he's like because he thought
about the open mic [ __ ] yeah and he's
like nah i don't want to do that and i'm
like oh my poor sweet innocent child you
don't know what real karaoke is like and
i took him connor was there
i went with uh dave as well from
boyinaband yeah and he was like that's
the most fun that he's ever had in japan
and like i [ __ ] told you yeah it's
it's honestly like one of the funnest
things you can do in japan i feel like
because
i think the thing about japanese karaoke
is that the song selection is [ __ ]
godly you want to sing anime songs of
course you want to sing anime songs you
have all the anime songs at your
disposal but if you can't speak the if
you can't sing the nihongo then uh you
got basically every major song from
england and yeah america could be a
tablet and they'll be foreign songs or
something yeah yeah you can speak like
uh korean songs and chinese songs as
well like
i i think i think the japanese karaoke
has a better selection of english songs
than english karaoke in england it's
it's insane right yeah um yeah like it's
it's one of the funnest experiences you
can do with your mates you can also get
costumes oh yeah oh yeah we did that
when we first came to japan didn't we
you can go down to the first floor
you'll know it's a karaoke building so
look like something out of cyberpunk
outside
they always have the neon signs or the
really bright signs yeah it's massive if
you've seen the floors if you see neon
signs it's going to be pachinko or
karaoke and uh the inside looks like a
palace i saw this pachinko they all like
a palace inside yeah go into go into the
building if your ears are bleeding it's
probably a pachinko
if it's not bleeding it's probably
karaoke yeah because karaoke is actually
soundproofing yeah
buildings have tinted windows so you
can't see in yeah so they're like
frosted but you'll you'll if you'll know
it's a pachinko building because when
someone enters it and the doors open you
can hear that [ __ ] from a mile away
yeah and like i i feel like
do the karaokes if they want to sing uh
anime songs or japanese songs do they
have like a function in a lot of
karaokes now that where you can actually
when he actually spells it out not in
like katakana
the selection is super limited you're
better off just like looking up the
english lyrics on your phone that's true
that's true that's true but uh yeah but
they have like tv sizes where they
actually play like the visuals and stuff
which is pretty dope
my favorite things is uh seeing what
kind of music videos they play with your
songs that you're saying during karaoke
because it's like karaoke videos are my
favorite
what is who films that who i'd like okay
i think the same people make the bowling
animation yeah probably
must be so like if you've never been to
like an asian karaoke a lot of the music
videos it's basically like the
equivalent of a stock a stock uh a stock
image
just with music videos right so you'll
have like this random i don't know what
my favorite ones is where is the white
guy at the bar it's the one yeah you
know the one i mean
he's just like a sad dude
it's like a sad specific reference like
one person it appears like every four
songs yeah oh it's like every queen song
is just like these five people just
dancing on a dance floor in this empty
bar and it looks like the saddest
[ __ ] party yeah
and yeah i don't know what i don't know
what company
[ __ ] film this karaoke music video
british i think
that's the thing because it's not asian
people it's uh it's all like either
british or american yeah i've seen it's
so weird i actually that's a really
interesting topic i like i i would
actually want to know who actually who
actually filmed these where where who
made these who actually made these ask
joy sound or something yeah maybe where
are these videos can i get yeah can i
can you link me to the video they look
like they're filming like the 90s yeah
they're really old yeah because most of
them are still on like a four by three
aspect yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you best
yeah you know you've like picked like a
good song or a popular song they when
they have like the actual music video
they're like oh we're singing good today
boys we're singing most of the time when
you're selecting the song it says if it
comes with the actual music video yeah
and if it doesn't then you're gonna
probably get a white guy at a bar yeah
cause the saddest thing is when you
select like a banger song or something
you're like i'm ready and then you hear
like a midi track and you're like oh
oh it's always
it's like like it has like a [ __ ]
banger like guitar riff or something and
it's just like it's like the worst
immediate sounding guitar ever
that's fun but no karaoke is great
especially especially with your mates
and it's a great like it's because
it's a great way to just open up with
your mates because normally you go to a
karaoke bar you don't really want to
sing because you don't want to embarrass
yourself in front of strangers but with
uh japanese karaoke you can just
embarrass yourself in front of your
mates equally yeah and uh it's a hell of
a fun time